qué tan importante es para el presidente
bukele esta mega cárcel Y cómo influirá
esto a la política del Salvador
Bueno es un gusto estar acá primero yo
creería que está que este proyecto muy
importante para el presidente porque
lo ha publicado mucho y él está
planeando que ahí mismo esta empresa
pues al menos cuarenta mil personas Pero
eso también ha significado que El
Salvador se ha convertido en el país con
más presos per cápita a nivel mundial
verdad
Así es el fin de bukele también es
acabar con las pandillas Pero cuál ha
sido el costo teniendo en cuenta pues la
vulneración de Derechos Humanos que han
denunciado organizaciones
internacionales internacionalmente o sea
con respecto a esto
Sí el costo ha sido grandísimo por
ejemplo incluso dentro de las
comunidades que antes eran asediadas por
estos grupos criminales por la Mara
Salvatrucha el barrio dieciocho
la misma gente se ha quejado de la
brutalidad con la que la policía llega a
catear a sus hogares también porque les
revisan sus celulares y a veces hasta lo
golpean dentro de los penales está
pasando otra situación he hablado con
varias personas que han logrado salir
libres porque no se les ha encontrado
ningún delito que imputarles
y describen en escenarios horribles por
ejemplo de abusos de golpes de torturas
Y al menos hasta la fecha van más o
menos ciento cinco personas que han
muerto y el estado no
ha dicho bajo qué circunstancia esta
persona han fallecido hay algunos que
han muerto por asfixias Y entonces todos
nos indica que han sido asesinados
verdad pero hasta el momento no se han
pronunciado sobre estas investigaciones
Jaime y que busca el presidente con esto
se ha mencionado también en redes
sociales pues el propósito de esta mega
cárcel Pero cuál es el fin verdadero del
presidente bukele con este gran proyecto
su fin puede mantener presos a todas
estas personas en el Salvador según las
cifras que el mismo gobierno ha dado hay
aproximadamente unos 80.000 pandilleros
y Yo supongo verdad Que porque él no
estará feliz Hasta no ver unas ochenta
mil personas presas y para poder tener a
tantas personas presas siendo un país
tan pequeño necesita una estructura de
desenvergadura de la cual no sabemos
nada no sabemos ni Cuánto costó ni quién
la construyó ni los permisos que se le
dieron para la construcción